as we wind down to the end of 2020 it
looks like 2020 will be the first year
that tesla
was net profitable throughout the entire
year after 17 years of trial
error and refinement elon musk and his
team have finally gotten tesla to be
consistently profitable
so how much do they make from their
cheap and expensive cars
anyways
[Music]
well starting off for this estimate
we'll be using the numbers under q3 2020
earnings report
tesla is rapidly increasing
manufacturing efficiency
and consequently their margins so if
you're watching this video well into the
future
their numbers are likely just looking
even better
with that being said let's dive into
their current numbers starting with
their gross automotive revenues
last quarter tesla pulled in 7.611
billion dollars in gross revenue
out of which 2.105 billion was gross
profit
however this does include revenue from
regulatory credits which is basically
just
100 profit so in order to find the gross
profit margin of their actual cars
we would have to subtract the revenue
from regulatory credits from both their
gross revenue
and their gross profit doing this would
reduce their gross revenue to 7.214
billion
and their gross profit to 1.708 billion
at the same time their gross margin
would also drop from 27.7
to 23.68 now there are a few more
variables that can skew this number
with the first one that comes to mind
being revenue from full self driving
tesla's revenue from full self driving
is not listed under automotive revenue
but even if it was it wouldn't make that
big of a difference
though tesla's full self driving is
quite expensive today coming in at 10
grand
tesla can only realize a small portion
of this revenue every single quarter
you see self-driving technology is still
in the development stage
and as a result people who buy
self-driving today
will continue to receive updates for
years into the future
thus it doesn't make sense to realize
all the revenue from fall self-driving
right when it comes in instead tesla
slowly realizes the revenue
over several years as they continue
making progress towards full autonomy
for instance let's say they push out an
update in q1 of 2021
that makes handling roundabouts a breeze
if roundabouts account for about two
percent of the total scenarios a car
faces
tesla would recognize two percent of
their total fsd revenue
and as you would guess when they're just
nibbling at the total fsd revenue every
quarter
this doesn't come out to a very big
amount for instance
tesla cfo zachary kirkhorn revealed in
q2 of 2020
that tesla recognized 48 million from
fsd revenues that quarter
in comparison to their gross automotive
revenue this figure is only 0.66 percent
so really shouldn't affect our math too
much even if this revenue
was listed under automotive revenue
aside from this
another piece that could skew our math
is revenue from leasing
but this revenue is separated out later
in the financial report
allowing us to just focus on automotive
sales comparing automotive sales revenue
and the cost of automotive sales after
removing the proportional regulatory
credit revenue
we'll find that automotive sales revenue
is 6.963 billion
and the cost of these sales is 5.361
billion
in other words after accounting for
leasing revenue and
profit tesla's estimated gross profit
margin for car sales
drops from 23.68 to twenty three point
zero zero seven percent
so from each car tesla profits and
averaged 23 percent of the price
of the car itself last quarter 88.28
of the cars tesla delivered were model
threes and y's
thus this margin should be pretty close
to the margin of these two models
though this number is likely slightly
skewed upwards by their high margin
vehicle sales
to keep things simple though we'll just
say that model 3s and ys are roughly 20
and that model s's and x's are about 30
with that being said the base level
model 3 has an msrp
of 37 990
20 of that is 7598
meaning that it cost tesla thirty
thousand three hundred ninety two
dollars to make a model three
but that's just the cost of materials
and labor that directly go into
assembling the car
it doesn't include the cost of
developing the car or selling the car
which go under operating expenses in q3
tesla reported research and development
as costing 366 million dollars
if we assume that this cost was spread
proportionately in relation to the
revenue sources
approximately 306 million of that
expense can be attributed to automotive
sales
or about 4.39 of the automotive sales
revenue
similarly tesla reported selling general
and administrative expenses to be 888
million
doing the same math about 743 million of
that cost can be attributed to
automotive sales
or about 10.6 percent of their
automotive sales revenue
in relation to the cost of the model 3
about 1
668 of the selling price goes towards
research and development
additionally four thousand twenty seven
dollars goes towards various
administrative tasks
if we add all of these up we get a total
of thirty six thousand eighty seven
dollars
meaning that tesla's operating profit
from each model three is about 1
903 or exactly 5.009 percent of the car
selling price
we can confirm this by looking at
tesla's operating margin
tesla lists their operating margin to be
9.2 percent
but if we remove regulatory credits the
number drops to 4.92 percent
or right about what we calculated so if
tesla decided to stop growing
and just run a profitable automotive
business after current scale
1 903 is how much they would make at the
end of the day
from each model 3 sold however tesla
isn't doing that
they're actually building giga factories
around the world
in fact tesla spent 1.005 billion
in capital expenditures just last
quarter again
if that is proportional to their revenue
streams roughly 841 million can be
accounted for by automotive sales
which is 12.09 of their automotive sales
revenue
this means that for each model 3 they
sell tesla is spending 4
593 to build factories and expand their
business
and if you haven't noticed yet this
indicates that tesla spends more money
than they get
for every base level model 3 they sell
they spend forty thousand six hundred
eighty dollars
now the regulatory credits do make up
for that discrepancy
thus making tesla profitable but that's
the raw breakdown of where exactly your
money
is going and now that we've figured out
the margins we can apply the same math
to tesla's other cars as well
taking a look at the model y the msrp is
forty nine thousand nine hundred ninety
dollars
or basically fifty k at a twenty percent
gross profit margin
it cost tesla forty 000 to make the
model y and
their gross profit from the vehicle is
10 grand r
d comes in at 2 195
and administrative expenses come out to
5 300
leaving tesla with an operating profit
of two thousand five hundred and five
dollars
if we add the cost of building factories
however tesla's total cost rises to
fifty three thousand five hundred forty
dollars
leaving them in the red once again
moving up to the model s
the msrp of the base model is 69 420
we previously estimated that the gross
profit margins of the s and x are likely
higher than tesla's overall gross profit
margin
so for the model s we'll use the higher
gross profit margin of 30 percent
this would mean that it cost tesla forty
eight thousand five hundred ninety four
dollars to produce a model s
and thus their gross profit margin is
twenty thousand eight hundred twenty six
dollars
aside from this r d will take up three
thousand forty eight dollars
and administrative expenses will take up
seven thousand three hundred fifty nine
dollars
adding those up we get a total of fifty
nine thousand one dollars
leaving tesla with an operating profit
of a solid ten thousand four hundred
nineteen dollars
or an operating margin of fifteen
percent finally
adding on the weight of capital
investments we get another 8
393 pushing up the total cost of the
model s to 67
393 dollars meaning that tesla is
actually net profitable with the model s
now one thing we should note is that
scaling up r d
administrative expenses and capital
investments doesn't exactly make sense
all tesla models use the same core
self-driving technology
so really r d cost should be evenly
split amongst the cars
similarly administrative costs of
selling a more expensive model
aren't going to really be more expensive
than a cheaper model
so administrative costs should be evenly
split as well
and as for building factories most of
the manufacturing might will go towards
producing the model 3
and y so really capital investments
should actually have a larger weight on
the cheaper cars
meaning that the model 3 and y are even
more in the red
and that the model s and x are even more
in the green however
tesla wouldn't be investing so heavily
into factories and the model 3
and y would likely be priced quite a bit
higher if it weren't for the model
s and x in other words the model s
and x are making up for losses with the
model 3 and y
so it only makes sense that our
calculations reflect this reality
with that being said let's take a quick
look at their final mainstream model
the model x the model x retails for 80
and with the gross profit margin of
thirty percent the model x cost tesla
fifty six thousand dollars to produce
and they enjoy a gross profit of twenty
four thousand dollars
three thousand five hundred and twelve
dollars goes towards r d
and eight thousand four hundred eighty
dollars goes towards admin
inflating tesla's cost to sixty seven
thousand nine hundred ninety two dollars
this leaves tesla with a sizable twelve
thousand eight dollars in operating
profit
or an operating margin of fifteen
percent finally
adding in capital expenditures that
gives us another nine thousand six
hundred seventy two dollars
propelling the total cost for tesla to
seventy seven thousand six hundred sixty
four dollars
this leaves tesla with two thousand
three hundred thirty six dollars in
their profit
or in a profit margin of two point nine
two percent and
that's how much each of tesla's main
models actually cost tesla
do you guys think these numbers make
sense comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys are excited
that tesla is finally proving consistent
profitability
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you